jeder hat eine andere Definition von
Heimat
meine Heimat ist Deutschland
ich fühle mich deutsch
[Musik]
bin deutsch
in erster Linie bin ich viel
Schwarzwälder tatsächlich aber ich fühle
mich trotzdem hundertprozentig als
Deutscher ich liebe es und es für mich
ist eine große Ehre Deutschland in der
ganzen Welt auf dem Fußballplatz
vertreten zu dürfen ich bin Deutscher
und jeder der das nicht akzeptiert ich
habe ein Problem mit sich selbst
Deutschland gibt mir
Heimat und Deutschland ist für mich der
fette Männer Brandung
vier deutsche geboren in der Zeit der
Wände was bedeuten ihnen Grenzöffnung
und Wiedervereinigung und was ist
Deutschland für Sie heute sie erzählen
es uns
[Musik]
sie reden von Herkunft und Heimat
aufgewachsen in der Kleinstadt halbweiß
halbschwarz wurde geboren als das Land
noch geteilt war was ist deutsch wer ist
deutsch
[Musik]
zahlenz ich bin Lukas Steier auch
bekannt als KostO geboren am 2.6 1989 im
schönen Schwarzwald ich bin Lehrer
Rapper Schauspieler Comedian alles drum
und dran und Deutschland ist meine
Spielwiese
was ich sehe was ich erlebe dieses Land
hat mich geprägt nord-ost-west viel
unterwegs bin Schwarzwälder geht es um
Identität als jedes Mal wenn ich
irgendwie zurück ins Schwarzwald fahre
dann beruhigt mich das enorm also immer
wieder wenn ich dann reinfahre und die
Berge links und rechts sehe und im Tal
runter bin dann gib mir das so eine
innerliche Ruhe aber trotzdem
gleichzeitig auch eine Energie das
schwierig zu beschreiben weil es
irgendwie wenig und viel aber irgendwie
passt für mich zusammen es fühlt sich an
wie Heimat sieht aus wie Heimat riecht
wie Heimat schmeckt wie Heimat
[Musik]
das ist zum Beispiel Alltag für mich was
ich jetzt mache
herzlich willkommen bei zurück hier auf
dem food Festival im wunderschönen
Hochschwarzwald in Grafenhausen was mir
hier machen natürlich viel esse und viel
trinkgeldy also guck mal mit viele
fragen sich ja immer wieso ein Content
Creator Tag aussehen kann das ist zum
Beispiel Alltag für mich was ich jetzt
mache wirklich sehr sehr lecker komm
kriegst auch noch was ab ich habe das
natürlich auch festgestellt dass wenn
ich auf Leute trefft dass sie mir
erstmal nicht zutrauen dass ich
Deutscher bin ich bin jetzt hier noch
mal mit der Franzi Franziska die jetzt
extra vom Bodensee beschert fahre du
weißt gar nicht wie mich sowas glücklich
macht und wie ich mich darüber freue
konnte das aber oftmals schnell
übergehen das Thema durch Sprache durch
den Dialekt weil die Leute haben mich
gesehen und haben dann erstmal ganz
anderes Bild gehabt und dann habe ich
halt im Dialekt schwätzt so wie jetzt
Schweizer würden okay das ist ja einer
von uns
gleich gleich wir müssen noch erstmal
[Musik]
das muss man Baden-Württemberg halt auch
können
Spätzle Schabe sagt man dann Spatz wenn
die so fett wäre
so jetzt haben wir gerade hier beim
Mexikaner gegessen da drüben zu Franzose
und da gibt es noch aus viele andere
Länder Sachen zum Essen früher hast du
Bockwurst gekriegt mit Senf und Ketchup
aber ich liebe sie das war's
mittlerweile krieg ich halt das alle
Länder was zum Essen und das ist gut so
dass ich einfach die Gesellschaft
dahingehend öffnet dass man auch was
anderes probiert früher ist ja bei uns
vor allem hier was zu bauen und kennt
frisst damit und das hat sich Langzeit
durchgezogen und jetzt öffnet sich das
was er mega schön ist weil jeder Nation
und jeder Kulturbereich was zu bieten
hat was eigenes
[Musik]
Chancengleichheit Diversität Lifestyle
Rechtsstaat Freiheit Deutschland Einheit
ja Deutschland Einheit ich habe so als
Frage da stehen lassen weil manchmal hat
man nicht das Gefühl dass es so in einer
das gerade auch wenn auf Bezug zu Ost
und West und auch manchmal einfach wenn
man selber halt irgendwie Erfahrung
macht die mit Diskriminierung zu tun
haben oder die einen irgendwie
benachteiligen ich glaube das muss jeder
für sich selber beantworten ob wir eine
Einheit sind was ist deutsch schwerst
Deutsch Rap war für mich mal mein ganzes
Leben mittlerweile nicht mehr so krass
aber mit Rap konnte ich mich
identifizieren also die Dinge die ich
jetzt in meiner Umgebung nicht gekriegt
habe ne also alles wo meine Hautfarbe
quasi Herbert diese Community auch ne
die hatte ich ja nie hier sozusagen die
habe ich im Rap gekriegt weil da man
Gleichgesinnte die haben ähnliche
Erfahrungen gemacht wird auch wenn zum
Rassismus geht meine Stimme meine Power
deine Zweifel meine Mauer früher war
früher und heute ist heute man wir
werden schlauer
für mich war Fußball sehr sehr wichtig
auch als Jugendlicher weil da kam halt
alle Kulturen und alle Nationalitäten
zusammen und es hat echt viel gebracht
schon geil das ist alles anzuschauen
meine Oma hatte alles aufbewahrt da bin
ich mega dankbar jetzt dafür zwei
Torjäger ich war ja Stürmer und wenn
irgendwann mal ein richtiges Scout
gekommen wäre hätte ich auch glaube ich
den Profi schon schaffen können aber es
war halt den Scout da aber wenigstens
habe ich noch die Artikel immer ein Tor
zu wenig ich war zweimal ganz nah dran
an der teure Kanone hat zweimal die
nicht bekommen weil ich ein Tor zu wenig
hatte tja so läuft es halt manchmal
die Nationalhymne bedeutet mir schon
viel also ich war auch immer als Kind
schon wenn ich da bin Deutschland
gespielt hatte ich war immer da und
stand mit der Hand auf dem Herz und
konnte auch immer schon auswendig man
hat sich gefreut dass so sein Land
spielt und ich sehe mich ja und habe
mich schon immer als Teil des Landes
gesehen deswegen war es schon so ein
guter Moment ja
guten Morgen herzlich willkommen hier im
Stuttgarter Neckarstadt und zum Fußball
Länderspiel Deutschland gegen die
Schweiz dieses Spiel ist eine Premiere
für die gesamte deutsche Mannschaft nach
45 Jahren der Trennung
neue Zeiten neue
[Musik]
ne aber eigentlich schon klar sich kann
es schon am nachvollziehen dass der
jetzt da nicht mitsingt ich meine der
war noch irgendwie paar Wochen davor für
ein anderes Land eingetreten jetzt von
Deutschland kann es schon verstehen also
das hat ja auch mit Identität zu tun
servus ich bin natürlich Fan und die
haben natürlich auch vielleicht von
meinen Sachen jetzt so ein bisschen
mitgekriegt wir haben die gleiche Liebe
quasi zum Fußball das eine natürlich
tatsächlich auch so der Fußball der
Gedanke einfach eine Fußball tatsächlich
kann man das auch ummenzen auf
Deutschland den man sagt bringt die
Leute zusammen sei es im Verein sei es
in der Schule sei es bei anderen
Aktivitäten um einfach da auch
Vorurteile abzubauen und das
Gemeinschaftsgefühl hat vorzuleben du
bist auch sehr genau für dich war es
wahrscheinlich dann noch krasser halt
mit mit nee zwei Jahre alt keine Ahnung
ja
ich selber habe ich eigentlich gar nicht
anders kennengelernt aber von außer zehn
doch natürlich von meiner Familie ist
schon immer so dass dann immer spannend
ist immer zuhöre dann noch Spitzel
irgendwas alles früher war das eine ganz
andere Zeit und heute ist ja irgendwie
für uns wir kennen anders wir können ja
nur offene Grenzen und über hinreisen
woran möchte aber klar manchmal Scherz
ich auch in meiner Frau und sagt boah
wir haben mal die verheiratet ja wenn es
heute noch so wäre
Nationalspieler wenn sie DDR noch geben
ich versuche mal ob ich so weit komme
es wird schon oftmals hinterfragt so
schwarz in der Nationalmannschaft passt
es überhaupt das Ding ist ja das von
Boateng oder ich wir haben nicht Eltern
die beide aus einem Land stammen wo man
sagen kann wenn der Spruch kommt immer
zurück gute herkommst gibt es nicht ich
komme von hier ist ich kann nicht noch
woanders herkommen
[Musik]
so jetzt hat erschrecke da ist einiges
los hier oben sicher Vogelnest ist am
Start
18 Uhr keiner hat sich an meine Haare
angetraut ich bin hier zu den deutschen
Friseure gegangen und die haben gesagt
wir machen den kenne ich sonst bin ich
so deswegen habe ich bis ich 18 war
meine Mutter mir traurig weil ich hatte
irgendwann selber versucht mir auch
selber die Haare zu schneiden weil es ja
keiner machen wollte
ja das ist aber kommt erst seit drei
Jahren erst in Deutschland ist erst
angekommen von Bayern und davor muss ich
nach Freiburg gehen nach Offenburg gehen
ja
das ist ja auch ein Teil du willst
eigentlich auch gleich sein mit Leute
und dann hast du ja nee aber du bist
anders dich kennen wir nicht machen
durch andere Haare was ist deutsch
schwer ist deutsch seht ihr mich als
Teil von euch bin im Herbst der größte
du glaubst mir nicht gern fragt meine
Boys meine Jungs meine Fan warum ich bin
wie ich bin Deutschland ich bin ein Kind
glaub mir wir können nur zusammen
gewinnen viele hinterfragen sorry ich
bin deutsch wurde tausendmal hier schon
enttäuscht in meinem Herzen schwarz rot
gold
aber trotzdem muss man trotzdem noch so
zusammenhalten
Zusammenhalt für den Zusammenhalt
für jeden was dabei von jedem was dabei
unterschiedlich wie wir alle hier jeder
aus einer anderen Richtung und irgendwie
passt das letzte mal alles zusammen